salut tout le monde salue les abonnés de
france 24 j'espère que vous allez bien
c'est à m sila avec ces attaques
tranchantes et voilà à nouveau de retour
on est à cannes pour la projection d'un
petit frère en compétition officielle un
film de léonore c'est vrai c'est une une
chronique sur 30 ans de d'une famille
ivoirienne qui émigrent en france à la
fin des années 80 et sur comment ces
trois destins vont être façonnée par la
france comment ils vont rencontrer la
france comment ils vont aimer des pc
certains aspects comment ils vont juste
construire à travers tout ça
[Musique]
personnellement ça nous renvoie à notre
histoire moi je suis je suis d'origine
sénégalaise mes parents sont arrivés en
france pareil dans les années 80 et ma
mère pareil c'est pas assez battu un peu
comme comme maman dans le film comme un
label dans le film et elle s'est battue
pour nous deux offrir la meilleure
éducation elle s'est toujours battu pour
qu'on soit les les meilleurs qu'on soit
humble dans nos dans nos projets de nos
envies dans l'eau dans notre place quoi
mais qu'on soit là tu vois qu'on se
cache pas en fait on n'a pas besoin de
se cacher en fait c'était juste bien de
pouvoir mettre un visage fictionné sur
ce que pouvait être
la vie de nos parents de nos oncles de
nos tentes à ce moment-là de comment il
percevait la france 2 comment il pouvait
être perçue par la france de voir ses
galères de voir aussi comment en fait
justement on était beaucoup plus que les
les stéréotypes et les préconçus qu'il
pouvait avoir autour de nous moi je
trouve beau dans le personnage de rose
qui joue notre mère c'est qu'elle est
beaucoup plus libre que je qu'on peut se
faire des images de la femme africaine à
cette époque là en fait ce qui me
faisait ce qui nous connecter à tout ça
c'était se dire ben on est vivant à
l'écran prenez autre chose que éclaté où
l'on peut voir ici et là c'est ça
franchement c'est ça c'est on n'est pas
que ces clichés la même si l'équipe là
je parle sous nous sous le sous la
couverture est sous la couette de
l'humoriste les clichés sont faits pour
grossir les traits pour pouvoir
en rire parfois pour les dénoncer en
tout cas c'est ce que c'est ce que
j'essaye de faire à certains endroits
mais ce film racontera tout autre chose
[Musique]
bizarrement je me suis jamais posé la
question de l'identité je les ai
toujours vécu c'est à dire que j'ai
grandi dans des écoles privées
catholiques dont je sais que j'étais pas
à ma place c'est une des premières fois
où j'ai été confronté au racisme
et c'était c'est une des seules fois une
des dernières fois en fait si si
si j'ai les si mes souvenirs sont bons
mais elle renvoie à ce truc là en fait
tous de ne jamais être à sa place en
fait où on est c'est à dire que par
exemple aujourd'hui quand je vais au
sénégal balle sous le français est ici
en france eh ben je peux être envoyé à
mon identité de sénégalais tu vois ce
que je veux dire
[Musique]
bien sûr forcément on arrive dans un
dans un endroit où en fait c'est pas
chez nous quoi c'est voilà on vient de
dons viennent d'une cité tous les deux
on a grandi dans des milieux très
différents donc quand on arrive dans un
milieu très guindé et très très petit
four bien propre bien petit four bien
champagne bah forcément on se dit alors
comment il faut être nous aussi on se
pose la question
et voilà on nous accepte un peu plus
après parce que voilà on en fait on est
des gens sérieux on est des gens sérieux
et on travaille bien évidemment qu'on se
pose ces questions là mais il faut aller
vite les faire disparaître parce que en
soit on a lorsqu'on a juste a à coeur de
faire bien les choses il ya plus de ces
questions là le disparaissent vous juste
aimer ce qu'on fait et y aller à fond
casser les portes ne pas prendre ne
jamais accepter le mot non je pense km
et il en est une belle preuve pour moi
je me dis à jamais à rien est impossible
on ne doit pas on est là on doit pas
être là on est là c'est justement comme
on est voilà comme dirait jb mpiana
exact exactement
merci france 24